September 25th 1967.
a thorogeno rocket carrying a Corona
satellite takes to the skies from
Vandenberg Air Force Base in California
Corona is an amazing program for its day
launching something into space period
was a brand new concept
it was a real game changer
because now it allowed American spy
satellites to Traverse airspace
undetected and take very high resolution
photographs of anything they wanted to
two years into its Mission as the Spy
bird scans Western Poland it captures
this image
among this really heavily wooded forest
are concrete structures
this looks like a whole complex almost
like a mini City here
the fact that a spy satellite was
designated to photograph this means it
ain't no Girl Scout camp
we're probably looking at something that
was of significant National Security
interest to the United States military
yep Declassified CIA documents revealed
the massive structures baffled their top
analysts
investigators turned to recent satellite
images
it just deepens the mystery as far as
I'm concerned
in one era these structures are visible
to satellites
and in another the forest has reclaimed
them and overgrown them
what is under these trees why did
somebody build something so big and then
just abandon it for decades
intrigued by what could lie in the
forest polish archaeologist Gregor
kioshvis is traveling to the site in the
satellite images
to be concealed in the dance Forest
planning to raises the question about
why CIA was interested specifically in
that place
I need to go there and see what features
survived until the present day
archaeologist Gregor kioshvis is in the
forests of Poland
searching for a long-lost Soviet
compound rediscovered using new aerial
images
this is one of the structures that was
visible on the classified satellite
Imager
CIA files reveal the purpose of these
structures baffled intelligence agents
during the Cold War
as hopes a narrow entrance way he's
found will help solve the mystery
oh wow
[Music]
the structures discovered from the air
appear to be just a small part of a
massive Subterranean compound
[Music]
this is incredible
foreign
looks like a digital tank
whatever was once here is long gone
but it appears to have been manned and
guarded by a huge number of people
[Music]
that would be septic tank
and bathroom
[Music]
so that would be the main electrical
room
and some wires there can be seen hanging
from the floor
oh
[Music]
one of the larger rooms yields clue
Clues to what the Russians were doing
here
[Music]
and at the both sides of this room were
very thick blast proof doors
and there are some relics of
a ventilation system
whatever was kept here required very
specific conditions
the temperature and the humidity had to
be controlled for all the time
[Music]
in a blast proof chamber the
archaeologists spot some artifacts on
the floor
okay so those are since
as an expert of the Cold War kioshvis
thinks he recognizes this type of seal
containers with nuclear warheads
visits aerial data has uncovered a
secret facility capable of securing a
massive stockpile of the most
devastating weapons known to mankind
but something about the size and shape
of the missiles kept here is unusual
the storage rooms are actually quite
small which tells me that they could be
used only for storage of tactical
nuclear warheads
tactical nuclear weapons can unleash a
destructive force 20 times more powerful
than the bomb that destroyed Hiroshima
but what's even more terrifying is how
they're used
the cold war is well known for the
threat of the use of nuclear weapons
the tactical nuclear weapon would be
used in the presence of your own troops
on a battlefield
the use of tactical nuclear weapons on a
battlefield is almost unimaginable
[Music]
with the push of a button commanders
devastate key targets before deploying
thousands of troops to fight it out on
an apocalyptic radioactive landscape
the reality of combat where everyone is
from head to toe in their nuclear
protective suits using machine guns and
their lobbying tactical nuclear weapons
at one another all the while
recovered Cold War files reveal that in
the late 1960s the Kremlin secretly
moves dozens of nuclear missiles to the
site in the image
just a few hundred miles from the
soviet-controlled border with Western
Europe
they disguise the missile bunkers and
surround the compound with Barracks
housing young families
the Soviet Union wasn't stupid they knew
that we were watching
the Soviets work hard to make this look
like just an ordinary military base
considering the fact that there are
tactical nuclear weapons stored all over
the place
which was well hidden in the woods and
it was well kept from the people who
lived nearby
from here it seems the Communists
intended to wage nuclear war the war to
end all wars
yet kiash visits investigation reveals
that this is just one element of the
Soviet subterfuge
this was a true Armageddon bunker
proof that there was nuclear weapon
capped within the territories of Poland
[Music]
the most proof that people lived once in
the shade of nuclear Holocaust
for over three decades the secret site
remains Prime to unleash nuclear hell on
European cities and American bases just
over the Border
they have no idea that in the woods
there are all these nuclear weapons and
so their lives could change like that in
one moment
following the collapse of the Soviet
Union the Soviet soldiers and their
families abandoned the site
leaving the area strewn with their
belongings and equipment
over the following years the clandestine
base is reclaimed by the forest
only to be revealed from the skies once
more
the truth about this facility has only
just emerged
and it makes me wonder
what else is out there
[Music]